ich habe früher relativ häufig mit
meinem cousin zusammen weil meine oma
geschlafen und da haben wir nachts immer
riesling geguckt mit meiner oma jetzt
habe ich gerade gesehen dass wwe
tatsächlich einen youtube kanal hat und
die machen monatlich 766.000 abonnenten
das ist viel in der tat und jetzt habe
ich mir einfach mal ein video von denen
rausgesucht und zwar page returns to
david gabriela kroll newcomers man die
rosen sonja deml november 2000 sehr
gutes intro luca aber wir schauen uns
das mal zusammen an
ich hab halt voll lang ein wrestling
mehr geguckt deswegen bin ich relativ
gespannt wie das jetzt sein wird also
ich klicke einfach mal auf play und es
geht die
warum fast sie an den arsch ich bin ich
sehr gespannt was da jetzt passiert und
sie einfach durch die luft gehoben
guckt euch das an sie nimmt sie und hebt
sie einmal über sich selbst darüber
jetzt kommt die andere greift ihn im
mund ich verstehe es nicht
hallo die wollten sie sich nur um arme
und auf einmal liegen beide auf dem
boden ich weiß nicht was der schiri da
versucht irgendwelche jede kräfte
versucht gerade drauf zu beschweren was
tust du versuchst du dir hochzuheben mit
deinen händen also den schiri steht hier
schild da so ein bisschen versucht die
irgendwie zu bewegen jetzt geht er weg
jetzt sieht er dass er nicht
keine jene kräfte hat er versucht was
macht dieser mensch ihr alter ich glaube
sie will ihm einfach nur ihre
achselhaare präsentieren was geht ab
informiert
feedback
oh mein gott oh mein gott ja ok
wahrscheinlich ist es page wenn schon im
titel steht das jetzt also anscheinend
page sie versuchte so ein bisschen
aufmerksamkeit zu erlangen
die beiden stellen aber noch umringen
sie will
was geht hier gerade ab wie hat auf ein
mal schauen was sie sagt alle jubeln
einfach ist sie besoffen alter ich
dachte gesagt jetzt sowas wie hey alle
miteinander
lukas buch erscheint am 14 12 es wird
ein mega neuestes buch gekriegt und so
gut wie geben buchladen könnte es auch
auf amazon kaufen der link ist halten
wolle
wer bist du überhaupt ein paar sekunden
später sarah ja jay devils besser
bekannt unter ihrem ring namen brittany
beziehungsweise pages eine britische
profi wrestlerin sie ist derzeit bei wwe
unter vertrag und tritt wöchentlich in
deren wrestling shows unter dem ring
nahmen page auf
sie ist verheiratet das hier sehe man
auch so ein wwe mensch aber ich würde
sagen wir schauen uns das ganze
spektakel mal weiter an
den hat sie dabei ihre brüste was
passiert hier ja die wissen auch nicht
wann wir gehen für andere leute in den
ring und boxen herunter oder was
ich kann ihr müsst euch dieses szenario
grad mal vorstellen da ist eine ganze
arena gefüllt mit menschen die sich zwei
frauen angucken die sich in einem ring
bekriegen anliegen auf einmal beide am
boden der schiri versucht diese beiden
durch irgendwelche je die kräfte wieder
hochzuziehen und auf einmal kommt
irgendwo page an sagt sie es zurück sie
ist allerdings nicht alleine zurück und
dann springen zwei andere frauen in den
ring und boxen die anderen beiden nieder
also was geht da ab in amerika damit
verdient ihr euer geld also natürlich
meine ich mal beschissener
youtube-videos aber ihr schauspieler wie
erich box to mein gott da kommt die
nächste ort aber auch die presse und die
araber auf die fresse opfer ein und auch
meine pages im regen ok dann abonniere
ich frag mich gerade wie ich das früher
mit meinem cousin meiner oma gucken
konnte als ich acht jahre alt war das
war wieder so ein schönes bild als er
selber fünf frauen leicht bekleideten
sommer ring und liegen halb am boden und
boxen sich bewerben
nein
die schlecht war das denn die
schauspieler als von mir spur lama
zurück wie sie weg läuft also hier leute
weg achtet sie läuft sie denn hey die
läuft versuchst du noch so viel
sauerstoff mitzunehmen wie es geht oder
was also diese drei sind jetzt wohl
zurück also zwei newcomers und page und
jetzt sind sie sich noch einnimmt sie
und
ich will sich die ganze zeit
unterbrechen so aber das ist also das an
freunde also ich weiß dass das geschaut
wir sagen stopp
j
si
also
deshalb wäre aber ich würde sagen dass
ich das jetzt erst mal wieder so ein
bisschen weiter kommentieren weil der
kommentator in diesem video days gar
keine ahnung page zeigt sich gerade auf
jemand den schiedsrichter und will jetzt
wahrscheinlich den schiedsrichter oder
boxen sie lacht jetzt ein bisschen
rummel sie hebt die hand und sie nimmt
sie am kopf und rüttelt und schüttelt
und greift ihre nase und ohren mit dir
zusammen dreht sich einmal homepage
einfach eine unfassbar hübsche frau
diese drei haben jetzt anscheinend
gewonnen zwei newcomer 4 pages der mitte
ist zurück meine damen und herren pages
beck haltet euch fest der eintracht
frankfurt flaggen nicht kennen
wisst ihr amerika mitten im niemandsland
ist oder arena die gucken sich fünf
frauen an wie sie gegeneinander rasseln
und dann auf einmal steht dass ein
mensch aus deutschland mit einer
eintracht frankfurt flagge aus der
ersten bundesliga verein gehabt das ist
ja das ist diese drei damen haben jetzt
diesen kampf gewonnen die anderen liegen
am boden zerstört alle natürlich tod
cage ist weg meine damen und herren
dicken das war's
das war's ich finde die tags von dem
video auch sehr gut und zwar einfach rom
haben sala hallo hallo freunde da kann
man wirklich nur klatschen für seine
schauspielerische leistung wrestling ist
definitiv mein lieblingssport das war's
erzählt vom video meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat das kenne man
leichter schreibt mir mal in die
kommentare videos auf die ich eventuell
auch mal reagieren soll also irgendwas
verstörendes dummes keine ahnung was sie
schon mit ich in diesem video gesagt
kommt am 14 12
mein buch raus da habe ich zusammen mit
meiner mutter über mein leben
geschrieben also darüber dass ich bei
meiner geburt fast gestorben wäre über
meine panikattacken und über viele dinge
die mit meinem leben bisher widerfahren
sind also 14 12 bekommt das würde mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr euch das kaufen
würde weil wir da eine menge menge
arbeit reingesteckt haben falls ihr mich
bei instagram und snapshot die letzten
monate verfolgt habt
immer schön geschmeidig bleiben oder